so in this problem here we're told that
the triangle ace is isosceles so that's
this big triangle right here it's
isosceles which means it has two equal
sides and we also know from isosceles
triangles that the base angles must be
equal so these two base angles are going
to be equal and this side right over
here is going to be equal in length to
this side over here we can say ac is
going to be equal to ce so we get all of
that from this first statement right
over there
then they give us some more clues or
some more information they say cg is
equal to 24. so this is cg right over
here it has length 24. they tell us bh
is equal to df
bh is equal to df so those two things
are going to be congruent they're going
to be the same length
then they tell us that gf is equal to
12. so this is gf right over here so gf
is equal to 12 that's that distance
right over there
and then finally they tell us that fe is
equal to 6.
so this is f e
and then finally they ask us what is the
area of c b
h f d so c
b
h f d so they're asking us for the area
they're asking us for the area of this
part right over here let me
that part and that part right over there
that is cbhfd
so let's think about how we can do this
so we could figure out the area of the
larger triangle and then from that we
could subtract the areas of these little
pieces at the end then we'll be able to
figure out this middle area this area
that i've shaded and we don't have all
the information yet to solve that we
don't know we know what the height of or
the altitude of this triangle is but we
don't know its base if we knew its base
it would say hey one half base times
height would get the area of this
triangle and then we'd have to figure
out subtract out these areas and we
don't have full information there either
we don't know this height once we know
that height then we can figure out this
height but we also don't quite yet know
what this length right over here is so
let's just take it piece by piece
so the first thing we might want to do
and you might guess because we've been
talking a lot about similarities making
some type of argument about similarity
here because there's a bunch of similar
triangles for example triangle c
c g e
shares this angle with triangle d f e
they both share this orange angle right
here
and
they both have this right angle right
over here so they have two angles in
common they're going to be similar by
angle angle and you can actually show
that there's going to be a third angle
in common because these two are parallel
lines so we can write that triangle
we can write the triangle
cge
c
g e
is similar to triangle dfe
to triangle dfe and we know that by
angle angle we have one core set of
corresponding angles congruent and then
this angle is in both triangles so it is
a set of corresponding congruent angles
right over there
and so then once we know that they are
similar we can set up the ratio between
sides because we have some information
about some of the sides so we know that
the ratio
we know the ratio between df and this
side right over here which is a
corresponding side the ratio between df
and cg so the ratio between df and cg
which is 24
is going to be the same thing as the
ratio between f e
f e
which is 6
and g e which is not 12 it's 12 plus 6
it is 18.
and then let's see 6 over 18 this is
just 1 over 3. you get 3 df
you get 3
df is equal to 24. i just cross
multiplied or you could multiply both
sides by 24 multiply both sides by three
you would get this actually you could
just multiply both sides times 24 and
you'll get 24
times one-third but we'll just do it
this way divide both sides by three you
get df
df is equal to eight so we found out
that df is equal to eight that length
right over there and that's useful for
us because we know that this length
right over here is also
this length right over here is also
equal to eight
and now what can we do
well we can make another
it seems like we can make another
similarity argument because we have this
angle right over here it is congruent to
that angle right over there and we also
have this angle which is going to be 90
degrees we have a 90 degree angle there
and actually said that by itself is
actually enough to say that we have two
similar triangles we don't even have to
show that they have a congruent side
here and actually we're going to show
that these are actually congruent
triangles that we're we're dealing with
right over here so we have two angles
and actually we could just go straight
to that because when we talk about
congruency if you have an angle that's
congruent to another angle another angle
that's gonna go to another angle and
then a side that's congruent to another
side you're dealing with two congruent
triangles so we can write
triangle
let me write it over here i'll write it
in pink triangle a
h b
is congruent is congruent to triangle
you want to get the corresponding
vertices right the converter triangle e
f d
to triangle e
f d and we know that because we angle
angle side
angle
angle side postulate for congruency and
if the two triangles are congruent that
makes things convenient that means if
this side is 8 that side is 8 we already
knew that that's how we established our
congruency but that means if this side
is 6 has length 6 then the corresponding
side on this triangle is also going to
have length six so we can write
this length right over here is also
going to be six now i can i can imagine
you can imagine where all of this is
going to go but we want to prove to
ourselves we want to know we want to
know for sure what the area is we don't
want to say hey maybe this is the same
thing as that let's just actually prove
it to ourselves so how do we figure out
we've almost figured out the entire base
of this triangle but we still haven't
figured out the length of hg
well now we can use a similarity
argument again because we can see that
triangle abh is actually similar to
triangle acg
they both have this angle here and then
they both have a right angle they have
one abh has a right angle there acg has
a right angle right over there so you
have two angles two corresponding angles
are equal to each other you're now
dealing with similar triangles so we
know that triangle
we know that triangle a b
h
i'll just write it as a hb since i
already wrote it this way a
hb
is similar to triangle a
g c you want to make sure you get the
vertices in the right order a is the
orange angle g is the right angle and
then c is the unlabeled angle this is
similar to triangle a g c
a
g c
and what that does for us is that we can
use the ratios to figure out what h g is
equal to so what would we say over here
well we could say that 8 over 24 bh over
its corresponding side of the larger
triangle so we say 8
over 24 is equal to 6
is equal to 6 over
not hg but over a g
six over a g
and i i think you can see where this is
going you have one third
one third is equal to six over a g
or we can cross multiply here and we can
get a g
a g is equal to 18. so this entire
length right over is 18. if a g is 18
and a h is 6 then hg is 12. and this is
what you might have guessed if you were
just trying to guess the answer right
over here but now we have proven to
ourselves that this base is has length
of well we have 18 here and then we have
another 18 here so it has has a length
of 36. so the entire base here is 36
so that is 36 and so now we can figure
out the area of this larger of the
entire isosceles triangle so the area of
a c e
is going to be equal to one-half times
the base which is 36
times 24 and so this is going to be the
same thing as this is going to be the
same thing as one-half times 36 is 18 18
times 24 i'll just do that over here on
the top
so 18
times 24
8 times 4 is 32
1 times 4 is 4 plus 3 is 7.
now we put a 0 here because we're now
dealing not with 2 but 20.
if 2 times 8 is
16 2 times 1 is 2 plus 1 so it's 360 and
then you have a 2
7 plus 6 is 13. 1 plus 3 is 4.
so the area of ac
of ace is equal to 432 but we're not
done yet this area that we we we care
about is the area of the entire triangle
minus
minus this area and minus this area
right over here so what is the area what
is the area of each of these little
wedges right over here so it's going to
be one-half times eight times six so
one-half times eight is four times 6 so
this is going to be 24 right over there
and this is going to be another 24 right
over there so this is going to be equal
to 432 minus 24 minus 24 or minus
48 which is equal to and we could try
this to do this in our head if we
subtract 32 we're going to get to 400
and then we have to subtract another
16. so if you subtract 10 from 400 to
390 so that you get to 300
you get to
384 whatever the units were if these
were in meters and this would be meter
squared if this was centimeters this
would be centimeters squared did i do
that right let me go the other way if i
add 8 if i add 40 to this 24 plus
another 8 gets me to 3 432 yep we're
done